Robert Pattinson was very honest about
how uncomfortable he was to be in his
words kind of representing something you
don't particularly like and Anna
Kendrick compared the filming process to
a hostage situation no matter what your
thoughts are on Twilight You couldn't
possibly hate it more than its cast did
these are Twilight actors who despised
working on the movies Robert Pattinson
thought the story was ridiculous from
the start like what am I doing with this
right kid I'm 108 years old he
complained that the hobby gets to any
vampire stuff and by that he meant I
mean uh yeah I need to kill anyone after
talking to Stephanie Meyer Robert
thought that she was in love with her
own fictional creation it's like this
woman is mad he didn't think all too
highly of Twilight fans either calling
them people who sit in front of their
computers and comment on anything to do
with Twilight at least Robert thought of
the fans when he was asked if the end of
Twilight was bittersweet for them he
could have been worse Robert at least
she didn't have Taylor Lautner's
experience with fans Roberts said that
if he wasn't in the movies he would just
mindlessly hate Twilight Rob also
complained that his contacts were so
uncomfortable my entire performance is
based on have extreme discomfort having
contact lens in your eyes and
considering how long it took him to
respond when asked about the cast member
who made his Twilight experience the
most special before he finally said sk2
face packs we were guessing that he had
a sort of hard time making friends on
set too you probably know Taylor Lautner
best for one thing isn't he own a shirt
those rock hard ABS may have been the
thing that launched Taylor into stardom
but at the same time the poor actor
didn't appreciate the fact that he was
always the only person with his shirt
off he wished that everyone could do it
once because it would make me feel more
comfortable Taylor also complained about
the horrendous weather conditions
explaining that in the books it's always
supposed to be cold and gloomy and the
sun can never be out so that's not fun
and Anna Kendrick can relate but more on
that later for now that wasn't the only
part of Taylor's costume that caused him
problems he hated the wig he had to wear
in the first movie it did not like me I
did not like it not fond memories but
worst of all Taylor was a little freaked
out by some of the franchises more
passionate fans he even remembers one 40
year old woman who started taking off
her pants the moment she saw him so that
he could autograph them how would you
feel faced with something like that
Taylor wasn't the only one struggling
with the weather as we've mentioned can
you guess what Anna Kendrick remembers
best and I just remember my Converse
being completely soaked through she was
stuck in the rain for so long that it
really started to get to her and I just
remember being so cold and miserable she
didn't actually have anything against
any member of the cast this is a really
great group of people and I'm sure that
we would be friends in a different time
but how easy do you think it would be to
make friends under the circumstances but
I wonder murder everyone but if you want
to be one of our friends we'd recommend
hitting that subscribe button now but
going back to Anna for a bit she
especially took issue with Kristen
Stewart saying that Kristen made a
valiant effort to be friendly but I
could tell she was putting her back into
it but considering Kristen was having a
miserable time on set too we can
probably forgive her for that and even
Anna felt that there was something
bonding about the whole thing like you
go through like some trauma event like
you imagine like people who survive like
a hostage situation Kristen had a hard
time taking some of the movies seriously
especially in Breaking Dawn Part 2 when
Bella first becomes a vampire and just
instantly forgets about her newborn
daughter you kind of ignore their duties
instantly they just kind of they just
want to Bone but end of day Kristen was
a huge fan of the books she actually
cried when she saw Bella's wedding scene
come to life exactly how she'd read it
ready but the role brought about a huge
lifestyle shift for her and it also came
along with a whole lot of other baggage
that she wasn't ready to deal with
Kristen had only just left High School
when she'd been cast in the part of
Bella and looking back she felt like she
was far too young to be able to handle
the kind of Fame that was thrust upon
her all of a sudden when it started out
Twilight was something I really invested
in but the more she came to see how it
mattered to so many people something
personal became not the most personal
thing it sounds like Kristen could have
used a mother on set like Elizabeth
Reeser Elizabeth was perfect for Esme it
was her job to play the mother of the
Colin family Esme just loves everyone
she can't help herself and Elizabeth
took that role above and beyond by
taking a certain wolf cub under her Wing
as well you remember what we said about
Taylor Lautner being a little
uncomfortable when it comes to overly
passionate fans well he wasn't the only
one who had to deal with it Elizabeth
said that Taylor was just 16 and still a
boy when much older ladies would be
asking me about his body she felt that
these questions were just really
inappropriate and we wonder just what
made these women even think that it
would be okay to ask these things of the
mother vampire herself you have to think
they would have considered that first
still even though Elizabeth has been
trying to distance herself from the
movies she said I think the success of
the Saga is the books the books are just
beautiful amazing great storytelling and
Stephanie is a great writer which is a
lot more sentimental than Nikki Reed was
feeling by the end now Nikki was glad to
move on from Twilight she didn't feel
particularly sentimental when the series
came to its end saying I feel like we're
all sort of ready to graduate middle
school and move on to whatever the next
chapter is but Nikki didn't think it was
all bad she said that in the beginning
it was innocent and fun and we were like
one big happy family so what changed
Fame of course Nikki felt that success
came along and changed everything which
was something her on-screen boyfriend
Kellen Lutz saw happening too Nikki had
grown close with Kristen while filming
for the first movie and thanked her for
her support through their rise to fame
saying if it weren't for Kristen this
would have been a lot more of
overwhelming but it was clear that
something had changed as time went on
even Kristen felt someone on set had
told the other actors if you don't have
a reason to talk to them don't just go
up to them which she felt was really
annoying but whatever friction there was
between the two all's forgiven now Nikki
Reed still calls Kristen a dear buddy
Kellen Lutz just didn't get Twilight
from the start he was very
straightforward about the fact that he
didn't like the script the way that he
saw it how scary would a glimmering
vampire really be it just doesn't make
sense
imagine that being confused by
everything going on around him went a
long way towards helping Kellen Channel
Emmett's famous himbo energy stay an
older woman huh you see why Kellen saw
himself as a bit of a joke on set going
on to explain that it was hard for
everyone in the cast to get along
because it's like pulling one person
from every click in high school he said
that the artsy kid sort of kept it
themselves because they were just so shy
but Kellen was able to make a couple of
friends while they were working on the
first movie he looks back on this early
period fondly just because everyone was
so
just themselves he used to go out to
different bars and concerts alongside
Jackson Rathbone and Peter fascinelli
but that obviously had to stop once the
fame got to them an issue Ashley Greene
knows well
Ashley Greene feels like Twilight has
ruined me she came from being pretty
much Anonymous to Super Famous basically
overnight or as she put it it was a hard
adjustment going from zero to a hundred
in a day and fame definitely came with
its downsides Ashley was essentially
ripped apart by the fanbase who felt
that at five foot five she was far too
tall to play the tiny Alice who's
described as being four foot ten in the
books Ashley thought these complaints
were just ridiculous I'm much much
taller than Alice's described but who's
four foot ten anyways yeah that's a good
point Ashley it's very clear to us by
now that she's just done with the series
if you're wondering about Ashley's
thoughts on seeing somebody else take on
the role of Alice she said meh it's
someone else's turn she's moved on to
other projects by now although she'll
still revisit those memories on her
podcast the Twilight effect she even
brought Nikki read on for an episode and
the two of them discussed how there was
a lot of ups and downs and some drama
and we were like a family but also in
our 20s and so there was kind of tiffs
here and there whether they hated the
story or they found themselves caught up
in the onset drama that was reminiscent
of middle school this cast definitely
had their reasons to be skeptical which
one of these actors comments were you
most surprised to hear we'd love to hear
what you think so make sure to let us
know down in the comment section